AT ON A
BELLE TIRE POWER PLAY AND SEIDER
A GIVE TO LARKIN, IN FRONT, OH,,
HAMMERED IN FRONT OF THE
KEN: THE RED WINGS POWER PLAY,
FABBRI LARKIN,
CUTTING THROUGH AND ONLY ARIZONA
SCORES FEWER LARKIN
AND THAT SHOT, BLOCKED AND UP
INTO THE NETTING ANDHRONEK, LEDD
LEDDY AND SEIDER T NO, IT
WASN'T, CLUTTERBUCK GOING WIDE
RIGHT THERE, AND WHAT HE WAS ABE
AND THEN MAKE IT
AND NOW IT IS 1-0 FOR THE THE FA
VERY THE
TRADE FOR GAGNER, ATHANASIOU AN.
HRONEK. WAS, HIS SAVEBRI.
PERCENTAGE, SO VERY GOOD BUT
JUST THAT HIS TEAM THE LINE,
OESTERLE AND BEAUVILLIER WITH
AND NOW RAYMOND
COMING UP WITH IT.
AROUND THE CLEAR, A PENALTY
COMING UP TO DETROIT,IN
THE NHL THE ISLANDERS,
HAVING SCORED 14 STONED BY
SOROKIN. FRONT-RUNNER,
LEAGUE WIDE AND EVERYONE TALKING
ABOUT RAYMOND AND EVERYONE
A PLAY
DOBSON, TOOK THAT SHOT.
HITS A LEG. THE
GOALTENDER FOR THE WAHLSTROM AST
TWO OF THEM OFF OF BACK FOR WITH
NAMESTNIKOV AND HERE, TO RAYMOND
NOW PUTTING ON